la place saint-paul de rencontre des
jeunes du quartier est devenu ces deux
derniers jours un guet-apens pour de
nombreux automobilistes victimes du
caillassage de leur véhicule taxi
policiers et des particuliers
ma fille qui était avec moi et bien elle
a une petite fiat 500 il lui ont tapé
sur la voiture il n'y a pas eu de pierre
mais là c'était tapé sur la voiture nous
avons été témoins dimanche l'après-midi
des voitures ont été caillassées tout
l'après midi
sans compter les lélés les mobylettes
qui roulent sur les trottoirs aviva leur
écoeurement lassitude de voir de jeunes
adolescents s'en prendre aux habitants
du quartier sur le marché ce matin peut
pourtant souhaité s'exprimer à quelques
mètres de là de très jeunes gens jouent
la provocation et l'intimidation ou
jetant des cailloux aussitôt écarté par
des plus vieux que sans justifier les
actes des jours précédents malik
s'inquiète pour l'avenir de la jeunesse
qu'il côtoie montré du doigt peut
encadrer en angle de distraction
aujourd'hui et de perspectives pour
demain il a déjà un les jeunes qui
trouvent pas de travail et à 2 il ya là
deux il ya des parents qui ont baissé
les bras et après vous après il ya eu
certains gènes et trouve pas d'autre
issue que les ventes des stups nous
faire autre chose en outre la présence
de crs sur le terrain les deux dernières
soirées ont été marqués par le passage
d'un hélicoptère de la gendarmerie
une méthode persuasive qui s'est greffée
au climat de tension à la loi est la loi
on doit respecter la loi mais bon le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui voir une
et l'écho sur l'eau sanitaire en plein
centre-ville en 2012
on n'est pas à bagdad ici il n'y a pas
des gens des des mafiosi vent il ya
quelques uns perturbons dérange beaucoup
de voisins mais tout le monde connaît
tout le monde
là on était un peu surpris et adouma
tacen d'ajouter que l'éducation doit
jouer son rôle est de constater avec
amertume que beaucoup de parents ont
baissé les bras